hello and welcome to this video playing
Vlad talk at the game that I recently
lost I am okay I remember that one I was
the Trump game okay yeah there are a
couple of interesting options this is a
little bit weird I know but I want to
play a little bit out of them out of the
ordinary night III okay so I want to go
c5 Bishop e6 is a little bit a little
bit odd maybe but it's playable and just
not bad
to get something else okay so I'm going
to take him and then I tried to put the
bishop on to d5 I can also just take but
that looks a little bit simplistic some
this and then e6 it took a bit of time
this this whole thing it should be 65
but the bishop now is really on a good
position oh very normal looking moves
Knight to e5 okay
not sure what's best there but this will
definitely lead to trades which I'm not
really against with white having the iqp
so it doesn't want to trade right away
tonight c5 is that's the idea one idea
for I'm not sure Queen b6 looks kind of
normal here preparing rook the aid
before yeah angling 495 I guess which is
not bad not bad
that he managed that he's now
threatening to take and play b5 yeah
it's not so great honestly right now he
has Knight a 4 and B 5 ok didn't see it
didn't see it okay I was lucky
okay now yeah just a 6 maybe but she can
take on b7
and blow a real fan of my position
somehow it isn't it is really annoying
that the night is on b5 I mean
absolutely yeah on c5 I mean
I have two ideas 95 and potentially
Bishop c6 a bishop c6 now it's not going
to happen
what is f4 f4 is really weird move I
don't get that at all
and I did my position is a little bit
it's a little bit a little bit
uncoordinated it's so 97 97 26 really
hot moves that wasn't so great okay
there was a bit of a sudden end I have
no clue about this sank what the
position was like I'm quite okay with
with this here here must be very okay
than the the bishop on d5 just it gives
me a good position and whites whole
setup is rather passive so it should be
at least equal for black but I'm not so
happy with what I did now from here on
97 and he avoided the trade and now this
this Queen b6 and then before I 95 that
really didn't that wasn't good I didn't
like it that was really annoying on c5
and you cannot quite get rid of it it's
really not so easy the engine just wants
to grab it yeah that is actually not
such a bad choice I didn't think about
that because I always wanted to play
against iqp
but this is not a bad choice I mean my
bishop is still accepting it Wow
exceptionally strong on that square that
was that would have been better probably
than what I did and yeah here and didn't
he have this I was really concerned it
seems that I have to shoot a three or
Knight g4 I did not I was a thinking oh
my god oblong of the night but it is not
that clear okay
he played Queen a4
and now I went a6 I mean the engine
always gives me an advantage so maybe I
was I was under estimating my map of my
possibilities here Nydia 7 is not liked
by the comp it wants me to play Queen to
e7 Oh what is the idea to play this
maybe it's like if you don't know what
the ideas you'll be playing normally I'd
ask with the bloody computer this is
possible because no matter the blunder
so Queen stupid so the engine wants to
go h6 Bishop d6 just just like improve
the position you know I wasn't so
optimistic there but my position is good
it seems f4 is a real move I did not
understand it at all
why would you weaken the whole position
here it just weakens it has no benefit
to play at 4 and now he blundered Queen
b3 and I'm in fact already clearly
better here I wasn't so sure because
somehow my position it felt a little bit
a little bit I was very concerned it
brought those Knights but I am already
quite substantially better here
surprisingly as I didn't I didn't see it
during the game that I would have an
advantage
I mean if you are a little bit like if
you look at is now things like that that
I was slightly concerned about look
father and look rather ridiculous and
like 26 there wasn't really concerned
but I had this feeling I could could
have overlooked something yeah hmm
bit pretty bit odd bit odd thanks a lot
for watching